من جهه اخرى كشف مسؤول امريكيون للجزيره
عن ان البيت الابيض حسب قراره بتزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات ابرامز وان الاعلان
الرسمي سيكون اليوم الاربعاء ونقلت وكاله
استفيده بريس عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان
العمل سيتواصل على صفقه دبابات ابرامز
لاوكرانيا وسيتم شرائها ضمن مساعدات
الامنيه قادمه واضاف المسؤولون ان الاعلان
الامريكي عن صفقه دبابات ابرامز سيتزامل
مع اعلان الماني بشان الدبابات
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه في
مؤتمر صحفي بمقر البنتاجون ان هناك تحديات
تشكلها الدبابات من طراز ابرمز مثل
صيانتها والتدريب عليها لكنه اكد في الوقت
ذاتي ان الولايات المتحده ملتزمه دائما
بتقديم التدريب للقوات الاوكرانيه عندما
تزودها باسلحه النوعيه
في اموان
اليوم وسيكون صحيحا في المستقبل مره اخرى
بدون الخوض في الافتراض في اي وقت
اوكرانيا
قدم من التدريب وقدرات الاستدامه مع ذلك
وصفها المتحدث باسم الكربلاند بيتربسكو
تسليما الدبابات ابرامز الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا بالفكره الفاشله متواعدا باحراق
هذه الدبابات كغيرها حسب تعبيري واضاف
المتحدث باسم الكربلائي لا تتفاوضوا مع
برلين على خلفيه التسليم المحتمل للدبابات
الالمانيه الى اوكرانيا كما شدد على انه
لا توجد افاق للخروج الى طريق تسويه بشان
اوكرانيا واشار ايضا الى ان افاق تطور
الوضع في العالم لا تعده بالانفراج وهو ما
يستدعي التاهب والاستعداد